so this is a new segment that popped up
on cnn i think just
yesterday actually and second we have to
turn down the capability of these
conservative influencers
to reach these huge audiences there are
people on youtube for example
that have a larger daytime larger
audience than daytime cnn and they are
extremely radical and pushing extremely
uh radical views and so it's up to the
facebooks and youtubes
in particular to think about whether or
not they want to be
that's your fault
that that part right there where you see
that there's people that have huge
platforms
bigger than cnn and stuff like that is
your fault
because it's been known that you guys
been lying
so people do not trust you anymore
because you've been lying
and lying and lying hence people are
leaving your platform
to go to another platform that they
trust it's not so much that
these people are having a platform that
is big is that
we can't trust you because you're
powered by
it's not you doing your news thing that
you're supposed to do
reporting the news investigating no you
clearly have an agenda
and people know that so they left your
ass
i'm gonna do your thing cool they left
your ass
you were triflin you belonged to the
streets
so they went to the streets and found
someone else and now you mad
oh look look at my ex she lives in the
bed you triflin
sorry i have to i'm not even mad
effectively cable networks for
disinformation
and then we're gonna have to figure out
the oann and newsmax problem you know
that
these companies have freedom of speech
but i'm not sure
we need verizon a t comcast and such to
be bringing them into
tens of millions of homes come on now b
yeah they're advocating for d
platforming now they're saying because
we don't agree with these people and
their ideas and we say that they spread
misinformation they shouldn't be allowed
on these platforms if people really want
to find them they're going to have to
dig deeper they want to make it more
accessible
and you actually saw this with youtube
where they were shadow banning a bunch
of news
and independent people here on this
platform they want to do this on an even
larger scale so this is what i said
when i said once you open this door it's
not going to close and once you start
cheering on a bit of censorship
it always leads to more because now they
think the solution
to fixing the problems of the world is
not for dialogue
but it's for making sure certain voices
get silenced
do you understand where this is going
right now they're just saying radicals
what's radical i remember a time where
me saying a male shouldn't compete
against a female in sports was
considered radical
you all remember that time yeah remember
one time when we said hey listen
i feel like there's a lot of issues
going on and man sometimes males in the
workplace do this
but we should also ask questions and not
be so quick that was considered radical
yeah are you religious i promise you
it's going to be considered radical very
very soon
i'm not fear-mongered you're seeing the
progression
you're seeing the progression i had a
video flagged for hate
recently you know what i was talking
about
my father dying flag for hate
wait what that fit that yeah you got
flags where
on youtube on the album preacher the one
that she was
yeah yeah it got flat flagged so
demonetized
[ __ ] didn't i just say that no you
didn't tell me that
that's fine i just told you right now it
got flak for hate speech flagged
whole flag china red rip when you're
talking with the
[ __ ] i'm not gonna repeat myself i'm
trying to understand bro i'm not gonna
repeat myself i said what i said it's so
dumb that i i i think i'm the problem
and i understand yeah you the problem
no you're the problem no you hate speech
yeah you see what i'm talking about
it's crazy but let's keep listening um
this is you know allowing people to seek
out information if they really want to
but not
pushing it into their faces i think is
where we're gonna have to go here
see so now now they're not even trying
to compete they're not even trying to be
on a level playing field
it's already proven factually that
trusted sources
are now giving priority on channels like
you on
on pages like youtube and so what ends
up happening is that if you're
independent
it starts to become a waste of time to
do stuff on this platform because of the
fact that
you're going to be deranked and they're
always going to push yourself like if i
google
or if i youtube trump it'll never show
me independent news networks or
individuals it always shows me cnn and
fox news
as if they're trusted which is your bias
listen the percentage of american people
who trust
their news networks is super low you're
talking about like lower than
20 to 30 percent yet you want me
to trust them on if this is what i'm
talking about with the conclusion but
it's different
yeah man that's why that's i've been
thinking about the issue
since you said it and i was like he's
maybe right
it's totally absolutely your fault and
i'm talking to the media right now
if people do not trust you you got to be
accountable for your stuff
you can't be like it's fake news and
it's fake it's your fault yes
in those news those independent there is
going to be fake news
as much as you produce fake news yep
now you're making me sound like trump
fake news
yep but [ __ ] is right
and there's no alternative there's an
alternative because at the end of the
day
youtube is owned by google if you try to
start an alternative they'll just
de-rank you on the google search bar
while they'll try to buy you out and
turn it into what they want see dude so
there are no alternatives people
will go to this vlog those aren't real
alternatives
there's no way to financially make it on
those places you should
put all your videos into uh bumble's
kimball dumbo
that that's a new platform that
everybody's good at yeah you know
it's really it doesn't work like that it
doesn't work like that so that's what
i'm talking about once you guys open
this it just leads to more and more
people are not talking about removing
podcasts that spread misinformation
who's to decide at one point i remember
youtube was
basically endorsing everything the world
health organization was saying
the same world health organization that
when asked about taiwan's existence
remained silent and had the most awkward
interview a senior who
official has raised hackles in taiwan by
appearing to
dodge questions about tywin's exclusion
from the world health body
during an interview via video chat with
a hong kong media outlet
bruce isleworth a canadian
epidemiologist
remained silent for about 10 seconds
when asked if the who
should reconsider taiwan's membership
after their video hookup
appeared to be disconnected the
interviewer called him back
this time iowa declared that if he had
contracted the
terrorists he would want to be treated
in china
we actually considered taiwan's
membership
hello
i couldn't hear your question okay yeah
let me let me let me repeat the question
let's move to another one then when
islewood was asked about
taiwan he stalled for close to 10
seconds
and avoided a reporter's question but
the reporter persisted
i'm actually curious on talking about
taiwan as well on taiwan's case
we decided to give dr howard another
call to follow up
and i just want to see if you can
comment a bit on how taiwan has done so
far
in terms of containing the virus
well we've already talked about china is
an assistant director general at the who
and is a canadian trained epidemiologist
ever since the pandemic broke out
he has constantly sung china's praises i
left
inspired and with a deep admiration for
uh
you know the common chinese people uh
that that i worked with
if i had 19 i want to be treated in
china
i'm just saying i don't know if i
necessarily trust these people to tell
me who's a trusted source
if they want to tell us that then sure
make a committee so we can actually see
who's involved
and how they're deciding who our trusted
sources are but
i'm sorry guys i'm sorry
she's going left she's going left
and uh we're bringing all right sure
no it's going left at the same time it's
going left
so this is the stuff that i was worried
about and you're seeing it happening and
now they're not even hiding it they're
just getting on platforms and being like
yeah we're less popular but we're not
even going to be fair we're going to
make the platforms make us a priority
so this is the world that we're going
towards and cnn's encouraging it the
other news networks are encouraging it
because they make their money and uh
yeah
it's just it's wild to me bro it's wild
to me and youtube has been complicit in
this
too yeah but you have to be careful
because you're you're you're having
the same rhetoric as a trump supporter
bruh when have we ever endorsed or
anything he says on this platform
and said we agree not a single time we
make one video saying on principle
we don't just we don't like some of the
stuff and everyone's like you guys are
what
rough you guys are too reactionary man
but anyways these are my thoughts
like i said hope you guys enjoy the
video today who knows how long we gonna
last but we're just gonna keep making
content until we're gone
and that's pretty much all i got so
that's it for today let us know
[Music]